for the first time marvel studios is
producing long-form epic series for
disney plus one of the series is called
wand division we have not seen wanda
maxum off envision since the events of
avengers infinity war and avengers end
game where do we go from that
wanda welcome home
one division fits inside of the larger
mcu in that these are characters that
we're familiar with and we love but
we're seeing them in a totally new
environment and in a new light we are an
unusual couple you know oh i don't think
that was ever in question
[Music]
let's roll and playback please
one division opens in a classic 1950s
black and white sitcom we are kind of
recreating a whole era of television and
trying to do it with this authenticity
for the first episode it's the start of
the sitcom land
it's to an audience and we filmed it in
front of a live audience it was
nerve-wracking but i think it it was so
rewarding and so funny what a charming
door knocker
and cut through the course of the series
we see several different iterations of
the golden era of sitcoms in television
[Music]
i'm fine
this begins in a lovely way but this is
the mcu so of course all is not what it
seems i think something's wrong here it
feels really cinematic and epic one
division is going to be a mind-bending
and a very unique story unlike anything
you've seen before
wonder and vision
aren't we a fight
[Applause]